um my name is Jason spires it's nice to
be able to use that name because for
many years the only name that mattered
in my life was mr. kay nine nine three
nine seven because that was my prison
number unfortunately at a very young age
I made a stupid decision to sell
cannabis and I ended up in prison and I
was never really the type that was real
good at school like I was smart but I
wouldn't sit around I wouldn't focus not
trying to make excuses but my parents
had drug addictions I probably didn't
have the best guidance but I still
knowingly made my own choices so I own
up to that but when I got the prison I
had moments in my life that made me
realize I had a distorted notion of what
success really was and fortunately when
I got arrested it helped my mother get
clean and sober and help my father get
clean and sober so I now had parents
that were actively involved in trying to
do good things for me and I decided that
I wanted to improve my education and one
of the things that I remember is my
mother went online to Khan Academy and
she would get printed out transcripts of
what the videos were talking about math
and she'd send me the transcripts and
I'd read over them and from that I
started realizing I understand how
fractions work I understand math on a
deeper level I was always good with it
but now I was getting the point where I
could actually perform well with it
while I was in prison I was able to with
Khan Academy's transcripts learn how to
do many of the math procedures that help
me perform better on SAT and when I got
towards the end of my sentence I was
able to a to a work release program
which allowed me to go to Community
College and I had to take the SAT
anticipation of transferring to a
university and I used the Khan Academy
SAT prep and fortunately I was accepted
as a transfer student to Stanford
universe
and little did I know that a year later
I would go to my classroom and mr. Kahn
be our guest speaker and I got to tell
him something that was very difficult to
say but was the truest words I could
think of and that was thank you um and
it's not just who he is because like he
said he did nothing personally for me it
was his organization it was having
videos that were easy to understand it
was being able to learn knowledge
without having to admit that I'm stupid
because I didn't already know it it took
away the embarrassment factor of having
to ask someone else and so if you're a
part of that organization if you're a
donor if you're miss door who gave mr.
Kahn the impetus he needed to make this
actually happen thank you because you
played a role in me now being a Stanford
University suit and studying computer
science after being locked up 15 years
without access to technology so I
appreciate everything that's been done
for me in my life
and there's been so many people that's
contributed to it but I can honestly say
that Khan Academy and everyone involved
with the organization and everyone who
has supported its expansion and growth
to other students has made an impact
upon me and I can only tell you that
there's so many other people that have
the potential to make my story nothing
if they can just get their hands on the
ability to learn the way that I was able
to which Conner cat is a part of